benoît nrj 12 c'est fini ah oui c'est
plus que si oui j'avais sauté triste
très triste franchement honnêtement
après huit ans je pensais être remerciés
un jour mais pas aussi aussi vite et
surtout qu'à tous mes potes qui reste là
bas donc ouais ça mais j'ai été beaucoup
touchée c'est vrai t'as tout c'est quoi
tes projets bah pôle emploi m'a proposé
d'animer les coller les colonies
ferroviaire j'ai des pistes
oui je suis contacté un peu à droite la
ruche maintenant je réfléchir si tu
travailles avec notre production aussi
sur des pilotes moi là bas et ce en
dépit des programmes menés la semaine
prochaine voilà exactement je vous le
dis et écouter banon on te trouve très
talentueux la merci vocationnelle
j'espère que les pilotes vont te plaire
on espère que tu vas trop maître daniel